Okay, so welcome back. Welcome to video
number 23, our second video in the risk
management phase, Portfolio Construction
Parameters. So now we're at the stage
again where we're assuming that we've
actually got positions, we're now running
a portfolio.
And what we're going to introduce you to
here is a lot of risk management
parameters for portfolios which are used
by professional hedge fund managers.
We're going to start with all of the basic
ones but we're also going to show you in
this video an introduction to beta and how
we hedge out market risk.
You'll remember very early on in the video
series we were looking at trade ideas when
we're generating ideas at the industry and
the stock level.
And we were looking at different types of
trades as in the cross sector trades, the
cross sector constituent trades and the
intra sector constituent trades.
Now all of these are spread trades and
essentially what you have when you take
spread trades is a situation where you're
naturally hedging out certain levels of
risk.
And what we're going to look at here when
we look at beta, we're going to look at
how we mechanically actually go through
the process of hedging out market risk.
So we'll go through the basic risk
management parameters for the portfolio
which all hedge fund managers use.
And we're also going to go a little bit
advanced and we're going to go into an
introduction of beta and the mechanics of
how it would work if you were hedging out
market risk for a single spread trade or
multiple spread trades.
So let's go over to the presentation.
Straight after the presentation we'll be
going on the computer and I'll be showing
you how to do this with using beta and
using these publicly available statistics.
And then in video number 24 Chris is
actually going to show you on the computer
how you calculate beta yourself.
So let's go over to the presentation and
I'll see you on the computer after the
presentation and for a summary of the risk
management parameters at the end of this
video.
Okay, let's move on to risk management.
Further discipline. So we know what to do
with losers. We know what to do with
winners. We don't get married to losers.
And the upside on winners could be
anything. So marriage could be a
consideration.
But when these positions are real in your
portfolio, you can have additional risk
management parameters that protect your
downside on losers.
So I'll just go through a few of them. And
again, there's no hard and fast rules.
There's no book you can buy at Blackwell's
WH Smiths that says this is the perfect
portfolio and here's all the risk
management situations you should apply.
That book's called this is how you should
trade. And there's a million of them that
should tell you something.
So there's no rule, but these are the risk
management situations that you would apply
to a standard portfolio.
First one gross exposure limits. So in a
retail brokerage account, if we set up a
typical account, we might put $25,000 in
the account.
What is that $25,000? It's called margin,
which is collateralized. And it's used by
the broker to pay for your losses.
So what happens on a day when your
portfolio is up $1,000? That $25 becomes
$26. The broker puts $1,000 in your
trading account.
What happens on a day when you lose $1,000
in your portfolio? You have to pay the
broker $1,000 and it becomes $24.
That's what the margin's there for. But
the broker, when you put $25,000 in your
account, on large cap stocks will allow
you to take roughly 10 times the exposure
that you've put, of the money that you've
put in your account.
So you could go all the way up to $250,000
exposure.
So what can we do? We can expose ourselves
at a rate that we want to be exposed to.
So we try and find the sweet spot between
the maximum amount of exposure that we're
allowed to take and the number that we've
put in the account.
So this spreadsheet here, exposure rates,
it's a very simple spreadsheet. It's just,
if you leverage 10 times, if you lose 10%,
you're out.
If you leverage five times, if you lose
20%, you're out.
So it just goes through all the exposure
rate, exposure rates from one to over a
hundred.
What about in Forex, if you've got a
hundred times exposure, what you've got in
your account?
Genuinely, that's what you'll be able to
do.
So you put $25,000 in your account and
you're allowed to take a position in
sterling US dollar to the value of $2.5
million.
What happens if you lose 1%?
You're out.
Every retail trader takes their maximum
exposure almost immediately.
It's crazy.
So gross exposure limits.
With numerical examples and percentage
examples compared to exposure.
If you opened an account with $25,000, you
want to give yourself a chance of making
money.
You never ever want to receive a margin
call ever in your life.
If you receive a margin call, it just
means you're a totally irresponsible
trader.
It means you don't know how to deploy
capital responsibly.
So you stop yourself from being human.
So you set an exposure rate somewhere
between one and 10 on large cap stocks.
FX never, ever, ever go over seven or
eight times exposure.
You can make money without ever being
stopped out or receive a margin call.
What is a margin call?
It just means you're stopped out on your
entire portfolio.
Have you ever received a margin call?
Are you kidding me?
Obviously not.
It's crazy.
The only time where I would ever have been
close was in the late 90s during the tech
boom.
Where what we used to do, because the
settlement was T plus three on physical
stock.
You would apply for the IPO, for example.
And let's say I only had £10,000 to trade
with.
To get an allocation of £10,000, because
everyone was applying for the IPOs.
You'd have to apply for £50,000.
And then they'd turn around and say, your
allocation is £25,000.
So if you were being sensible, you'd take
£10,000.
If you were being silly, you'd take
£25,000.
Because you don't have to pay for it for
three days.
So then if it went up, you'd trade out for
a big profit.
Because you'd never have to actually pay
for it.
Now it's different.
So I did that a few times.
But then stopped myself out.
So I didn't get a call for the money.
Once you get the phone call for the money
and you can't afford it, you're stopped
out.
So gross exposure limits.
Large cap stocks, four to five times.
Currencies, six to eight.
But to get to that point, you have to be
making money first.
So when you start out, you're going to
build your portfolio from zero to, if
you're in large cap stocks, maybe three or
four times exposure.
And then as you make money, you build and
build and build.
And you can take higher exposure rates.
So let's go through a little example.
So assume we've got this $25,000 deposited
on account.
And we just say, I'm going to limit myself
to four times exposure.
I'm going to limit myself to four times
exposure before and get a 5% return before
I increase my position size.
Yeah?
If you make 5% here, what's going to
happen in your portfolio if you've got a
well diversified long short portfolio,
eight to ten positions?
What's going to happen?
If you make 5%, what's going to happen if
you make 5% and you're four times exposed?
So your exposure is 100, yeah?
So you're going to make five grand.
So your 25 now goes to 30.
Now you've got 30 available in your
account.
And if you increase your exposure and at
the same time increase your diversity,
you're not actually increasing your risk
by as much as you think.
Because the positions here compared to
here are having a less contribution to the
outcome of the profit and loss of your
portfolio.
So as you go on the journey, you're doing
a couple of things.
When you're making money, you're pulling
from box A because now you're going to go
and increase your exposure.
So what are you doing?
You're saying, actually, I'm quite good at
this trading game.
I'm going to invest more money in myself.
So I'm going to increase my exposure rate.
So you're pulling from box A on your
portfolio as a whole, yeah?
You increase your exposure rate.
Now you've got a 20% cushion, but you're
more diverse.
So now you've got, say, 12 positions in
your portfolio instead of eight.
So actually your risk is staying the same
roughly here.
Now what happens if you go from 150,000
making 5% up to six times exposed?
So you make 5% on 150.
You make seven and a half grand.
And then you've got 37 and a half grand in
your portfolio.
And you go up to 225.
Make sense?
So you increase your exposure as you're
making money, but then you've got to have
an ultimate limit.
Because as soon as you start going over
six times, no matter how diverse you are,
what happens?
Well, there's going to be volatility in
your portfolio.
If it's a long, short S&P 500 portfolio,
what can you make or lose on a normal day?
35 basis points?
What if you have a two standard deviation
day in the S&P 500 and everything goes
wrong?
You can lose 2%.
So as soon as you start going over that
five, six times level, you're starting to
play a dangerous game.
Now, if you mix currencies into it, the
makeup and volatility of your portfolio
starts to look different.
And this is why professional traders stick
to five times in large cap situations as a
gross exposure limit.
Because once you start going over that,
you start to play a dangerous game with
the two standard deviation day.
You can be stopped out on lots of
positions all at one time and just end up
back at square one.
And what you want to do in an ideal
situation is be somewhere here with a mix
of large cap commodities and Forex.
Somewhere between here, after having made
money in two steps.
And grinding out a solid return every
month.
Trying to do it every month.
Yeah.
And then what happens if you do that for a
year?
And at the end of the year, you're up 20,
25%.
What's happened?
Well, if you're five times exposed and
you're up 20%, you've doubled your money.
What do you say to yourself at the end of
year one?
I'm quite good at this trading game.
I like the fact that I've doubled my
money.
I've done all the right things when I make
I've done all the right things when I lose
money.
And I've had discipline.
I've added to winners.
I've cut losers.
And I'm up 20% on the year with a 5%
exposure rate on average.
And I've doubled my money.
Looks like I'm quite good at this game.
Stick another 25 grand in your trading
account.
And double up.
Pull from box A.
Repeat and rinse year two.
Stick another 50 grand in your trading
account.
Then you've got a two year track record
and you're about to blow the numbers
through the roof in year three.
What happens next?
Everybody wants to give you money to
invest in you and now you're a
professional trader.
What do the retail traders do?
Literally the opposite.
Start off 10 times exposed.
Lose 10%.
Wiped out.
In the 90-90-90.
Work really hard all year.
Save up another 10 grand.
Do it again.
That's all you have to do.
What about net exposure limits?
That's a gross exposure limit.
What about if you wanted to place a net
exposure limit in your portfolio?
Let's go through nets.
So let's say you put a net limit of 50% on
a $100,000 portfolio.
So $50,000.
Your net exposure is just in dollar terms.
Your long exposure minus your short
exposure over your gross exposure.
So let's have a look at case one.
Long exposure 50.
Short exposure 50.
Your net exposure is 0%.
Your gross is 100 all the time in each
case.
Here your net's 0.
Case two.
Long exposure 70.
Short exposure 30.
Net long 40%.
Now what you're actually doing by going
net long if you're trading stocks.
Is you're going net long if you're taking
a net position in that situation you're
net long the market 40%.
So you're actually taking a view on the
market.
So it's questionable whether you should
have that 40%.
Because you could just go and buy the S&P
500.
Because that's the view you're taking.
Yeah.
And on.
Case three.
Long exposure 40.
Short exposure 60.
Minus 20% net short.
You're actually taking a 20% bet cash for
cash that the market's going to go down.
So you've accepted market risk.
So you have to ask yourself the question
should I actually just sell the S&P 500 or
sell the market.
Whatever the whatever the index is you
like to short.
But having a limit stops you from being
silly or doing stupid things.
Like having a huge exposure rate to the
market.
Now everybody who's got everybody who's
got a pension.
Where they've got 30 stocks long.
And no shorts.
Thinks they're really clever when the
market goes up.
Those stocks are not up because those
stocks are great stocks are great
companies.
They're up because the market's up.
They're long market risk sector risk and
stock risk.
And they all run into a cave.
And you never hear from them again.
When the stock when you were in a bear
market and the stock market's down 50%.
Because their pensions are down 50%.
So in those situations you're accepting
market risk.
So be honest with yourself.
So having a net exposure limit stops you
from doing that.
You can do it a little bit if you want.
That's fine.
But know the risk you've got.
So maybe you put on an exposure limit of
25%.
A net exposure limit of 25%.
And say never ever ever ever will I ever
be more than long $25,000 or short $25,000
of the market.
Because that's essentially the position
you've got on.
What about hedging out the market risk?
Let's say you've got a £20,000 limit on a
spread trade.
Or a £10,000 limit on a single position.
We'll go on to position limits and theme
limits next.
How do you hedge out the market risk on
two stocks?
So beta is just for every unit that the
market moves, the historical move of the
stock.
So if the market moves one, if a stock has
a beta of 1.15, history says the stock
will move 1.15.
But when you're hedging out market risk,
you've got beta values of two stocks.
So how do you hedge out the market risk?
But what you do is you take the beta ratio
of the long and divide it by the beta
ratio of the short.
And you get a beta of the spread.
You get a beta of the ratio.
So in terms of beta hedging, what we're
going to send you is the beta hedge
example that you've just seen.
A beta hedge step-by-step guide.
And that guide is going to show you how to
actually calculate your own beta in an
Excel spreadsheet.
By taking the historic data of the market
and the stock.
So you can go out publicly and get the
betas.
You can get three months, six months,
twelve months, three year, five year.
But you can calculate your own if you
want, if you struggle to find the beta.
Now, caution, beta isn't perfect.
So it doesn't mean that if we're trying to
hedge out the market risk, we can be
successful all the time.
Because the beta value is just the
historical data of the stock in relation
to the market.
If it does change.
If it does change, you'll be told in your
portfolio that it's changed.
Because you'll be losing money because of
it.
And you won't understand why, when the
market moves one unit, the historical beta
doesn't work quite the way you expected.
So it's not exact science.
Because beta can change.
So we rely on it as a tool to attempt to
hedge out market risk as best we can.
But we do not rely on it with our lives.
And everyone forgets this in the
professional trading world, when they
spend years building sophisticated models,
and then beta just changes.
But that's why you have other risk
parameters and risk management parameters
in your portfolio.
To stop you being human.
Not admitting that your beta calculations
are wrong is pulling from box A when
you're wrong.
Does that make sense?
So you'll get theme limits, single asset
position limits.
What about a $100,000 exposure portfolio
with a 10% single position limit?
So you just say to yourself, if my gross
exposure limit is $100,000, I'm never
going to go into one position over
$10,000.
And as you make money, guess what?
The notional value of your single position
limits go up.
So you actually get rewarded for making
money by doing nothing.
Which is great.
That's what we want.
So very typically, that's quite this
example that we've gone through today of a
$25,000 situation where you put it in a
margin account and in step one, you have
$100,000 exposure.
It's a very typical profile of an
institute trader.
So the average institute trader is about
30,000 pounds in their trading account.
Some have 10, some have over 100.
One guy has over 300,000 in his account.
But the average profile is about 30,000
pounds when you strip that guy out.
So typically, most people have between 100
and 150,000 pounds exposure, something
like that.
And that's what your portfolio would look
like in a spreadsheet or in a trading
account.
You just have five longs, five shorts, 10%
position limits.
And if you're doing beta adjusted trades
on spreads, then your spread is 20,000
limit.
And your cash for cash situation has to
come below 20,000 when you add them up.
So your gross exposure on the spread is no
higher than your theme limit.
What about a portfolio stop loss?
So you would hope that in a well
diversified long short portfolio, that if
you had five longs and five shorts, that
some would be working, some wouldn't be
working, but net net, you might be making
money or losing a little bit.
You put a stop loss on your portfolio.
Large cap stocks, S&P 500, FTSE 100.
If you're putting stop losses on each
position of 10%, what do you think would
be a sensible portfolio stop loss?
Well, one position, if you get stopped
out, will cost your portfolio 1%.
Stop losses we're trying, even when we put
one on the portfolio, to put a stop loss
on the portfolio that gives us a good
chance of making money, but not in the
realms of stupidity where we're not having
discipline.
So a sensible portfolio stop loss might be
10%.
Or somewhere between five and 10%.
Because 10% just means you've got all of
your positions wrong and you've been
stopped out.
So you're going to get stopped out anyway.
Because they've all cost your portfolio
1%, all at the same time.
Whatever you do, stop yourself out, take a
break for one or two months and reassess.
Because you've obviously had a nightmare.
If you threw 10 darts at a board and
selected five longs and five shorts with
darts, you'd get one right.
So for you to be stopped out on 10
situations in a 10-position portfolio,
there must be something really, really
wrong with your selecting, with your
ideas.
So you're stopped out, you go on holiday,
you think about it, think about whether
trading is the right profession for you.
But the key is, is if you started off with
25,000 and you had 100,000 exposure, you'd
be down to 15 in your trading account.
You're not out the game.
You've still got cash.
You've still got the ability, you've still
got chips to come back to the table.
That's why you have a stop loss on your
portfolio.
So if you've got 10% stop losses and the
profile of your portfolio is 10 positions,
five long, five short, over the S&P 500,
large cap stocks, or very large liquid
currencies and commodities.
And you've got a 10% stop loss on those
positions.
For all of them to go wrong, there must be
something really, really, really wrong.
So stick a 10% stop loss on the entire
portfolio.
Drop 10 grand, what's the worst thing
that's going to happen?
You've still got 15.
But you've pulled from box B because
trading might not be the right profession
for you.
So for the risk management section, very
simply, all of those risk management
parameters basically dictate how your
portfolio will be structured at maximum
parameters.
Why do we have those maximum parameters?
Because we're trying to stop ourselves
from being human.
So position limits, theme limits, net
exposure limits, gross exposure limits,
stick within those parameters.
You'll be the opposite of human.
Okay, welcome back to the computer screen.
What we're going to have a look at now is
beta and specifically how we use beta to
hedge out market risk.
So we're going to look at a simple example
first of one stock long versus one stock
short.
And then later we're going to look at a
more complicated example where we're
representing our idea through a theme
where we've got two longs and two shorts
representing the same idea and how we
hedge out market risk in that scenario.
So let's start with the simple example.
And here we're looking at a trade where
we're thinking about going long Chevron
and short AstraZeneca.
Now this trade, if you refer back to the
original notes, this trade is a cross
sector constituent spread trade.
So slightly higher risk than other spread
trades.
So if we're looking at going long Chevron
and short AstraZeneca, we're looking at
going long a cyclical stock versus short a
defensive stock because Chevron's in the
oil sector and AstraZeneca is in the
pharmaceutical sector.
So the oil sector, Chevron's earnings, so
Chevron being in the oil sector, Chevron's
earnings are more sensitive to the
business cycle than AstraZeneca's.
So if we're backing out what we're looking
at in terms of our views here, at this
stage we're clearly bullish on the world
because we're leaning to being long
cyclicals and short defensives.
So if we were bearish on the world, we
wouldn't be looking at this trade at all,
we'd be looking at it the other way
around.
So we've got the betas here where we've
given Chevron a beta of 1.32 and
AstraZeneca a beta of 1.12.
These aren't the actual betas of Chevron
and AstraZeneca.
The actual betas you can get online or in
the download section in the spreadsheets
that we've provided.
We've given fictional betas for
illustrative purposes here, so don't worry
about it.
You can get the real betas online or in
the download section.
We're just using these betas for
illustrative purposes.
So we've given Chevron a beta of 1.32 and
AstraZeneca a beta of 1.12.
And the beta ratio between Chevron and
AstraZeneca is 1.1786.
So what does that mean?
It just means that for every one unit move
in the market, Chevron moves 1.1786 times
more than AstraZeneca.
That's all it means.
In terms of committing capital, what that
means is that for every dollar that you
put in to Chevron, going long Chevron, you
have to short 1.1786 times that $1.
to hedge out the market risk in
AstraZeneca because AstraZeneca moves a
lot less than Chevron.
So let's have a look at this in terms of
dollar commitment.
So let's say, for example, you have a
restriction in your portfolio of $20,000
in one spread trade, meaning that your
self-imposed restriction for any one
spread trade is $20,000.
So if you committed $10,000 long to
Chevron, you would have to short,
according to the beta ratio, $11,786 of
AstraZeneca.
Well, if you did that, this would just
take you over your limit of $20,000.
So your exposure would be 21.786.
And that breaks your limit, so you can't
do that.
So you would have to actually short,
sorry, you would have to actually go long
less than $10,000 in order to meet your
self-imposed exposure limit of $20,000.
So to make sure that you're within your
limit, you would have to go long $9,180 of
Chevron and short $10,819 of AstraZeneca.
Now, why are we doing this? Why are we
hedging out market risk?
Well, let's think about this a bit more in
depth.
So imagine if the market now fell 10%.
Let's say we had this trade-on and the
market dropped 10%.
So Chevron would drop 13.2% and
AstraZeneca would drop 11.2%.
So in that situation, imagine if you were
just long $10,000 of Chevron and short
$10,000 of AstraZeneca.
Well, all that would happen is you would
lose 2% on that trade.
So you've basically got in that situation
an implied market risk.
Because if the market drops 10%, you're
going to actually lose money on this
trade.
Because Chevron moves for every one unit
that the market moves, Chevron moves more
than AstraZeneca.
So what do you actually have to do?
Well, what you have to do is actually
commit more capital on the side of
AstraZeneca.
So now imagine if you use the beta ratio
and you hedge out this market risk.
Well, if the market fell 10%, then you
would have less money committed on the
side of Chevron
and more money committed on the side of
AstraZeneca versus the example of $10,000
long and $10,000 short.
Which means if the market dropped by 10%,
even though Chevron would drop by 13.2%
and AstraZeneca would drop by 11.2%, you
wouldn't lose any money on that trade.
So on that move, you would actually come
out, roughly speaking, you would come out
not making or losing any money.
Now the obvious question is, well, what
happens when the market goes up?
Well, when the market goes up, it's the
same situation.
If the market went up 10%, Chevron would
go up by 13.2% and AstraZeneca would go up
by 11.2%.
And you wouldn't make or lose any money on
the trade.
But that's missing the point.
Because what you're actually doing here is
you're hedging out the market risk and
you're isolating sector and stock risk.
So whether the market goes down 10% or
goes up 10%, it doesn't matter.
Because the whole point of this trade is
that you're hedging out the market risk.
So the statement that you're making here
when you put this trade on is that
regardless of what the market does,
Chevron is just going to outperform
AstraZeneca over time.
So if you're bullish on the world, and in
this example we're assuming that you are,
where your world view is bullish and
you're leaning into buying cyclicals and
shorting defensives, the obvious question
is, well, if you beat a hedge and the
market goes up, then why would you do
that?
Well, let's put it this way.
If you wanted to have a market bet, then
you could just buy the market.
So you just go and buy the S&P 500.
But in this example, what you're actually
doing is hedging out the market risk so on
a day-to-day basis you don't make or lose
any money on this trade.
But then when the news comes out at some
point that one of Chevron's competitors
has guided up their earnings and Chevron
goes up in sympathy, well, Chevron is just
going to go up and AstraZeneca is going to
do nothing.
And imagine, for example, if the news came
out that Chevron was guiding up their
earnings, well, Chevron themselves would
just go up, let's say, 5%, 10%, and
AstraZeneca just wouldn't do anything.
All you're doing here is hedging out the
market risk so that on a day-to-day basis,
on a normal day in the stock market, when
nothing is really happening and there's no
news out, you don't make or lose any
money.
But also if there's an external shock,
because you're beta hedged, you should
come out of that situation not making or
losing any money.
So that's why we beta hedge.
That's why we hedge out market risk so we
can isolate the risk that we want to be
exposed to.
As in this example, we want to be exposed
to cyclicality on the long side and we
want to be exposed to being short
non-cyclicality.
So when the fundamental news flow comes
through that Chevron and that Chevron's
earnings are going higher,
we're exposed to that but in the process
we're actually hedging out the overall
market risk.
So you should be able to understand that
it's a fairly straightforward situation.
Now what we can do is, for example, start
having a look at an example of where the
beta ratio is very, very high.
So let's have a look, for example, if we
change the beta ratio to 3.
Well, when we change the beta ratio to 3
or the beta ratio becomes very high,
the gross exposure goes way out, way out
away from our self-imposed $20,000 spread
trade limit as our example.
So what would we have to do?
Well, we'd have to bring this right in to
$5,000 long in Chevron and short $15,000
of AstraZeneca.
Now when you have very high beta ratios,
you really have to start asking yourself
the question.
You know, on a very, very high beta ratio,
is this really an effective trade?
Because for every $1 of capital I commit
on the long side, I have to commit $3 of
capital on the short side.
That just means your short is extremely
capital hungry, meaning that this might
not actually be a trade where your capital
is best used.
So what you're better off doing is
probably finding trades where the beta
ratio is actually lower.
And I think you're probably better off
making sure that your beta ratio is below
2.
You should really be questioning yourself
or questioning a trade in terms of capital
commitment that is, that has a beta ratio
above 2.
Because it just means that the short or
the hedge is extremely capital hungry,
meaning that the stock on the short side
requires a lot of capital in order to
hedge out market risk.
There should be more effective shorts or
more effective hedges out there that you
can commit capital to in order to hedge
out the market risk.
So you should always be questioning a big
or large beta ratio.
So that's the simple example.
It's not too hard to understand what you
should be doing here in terms of your
processes is going through the idea
generation process, getting your trades
onto your watch list, as we've seen, and
managing your watch list properly and then
deciding when you want to put on your
trades.
Whether you want to hedge out market risk.
If you want to hedge out market risk, how
much of the market risk you want to hedge
out.
If you want to hedge out all of the market
risk, that's totally fine.
It's all about choices.
And if you've got a net restriction in
terms of market exposure in your
portfolio, then you know that you're going
to have to fall inside that parameter in
order to have particular trades on.
So just remember as well that having a
beta ratio above 2, you need to question
that really because it might not be an
effective hedge or an effective way to
hedge out the market risk.
So that's the simple example.
Let's now move on to the more complicated
example of theme betas.
Okay, so the example we're going to look
at here is a slightly more complicated
example of how we use beta to hedge out
market risk.
What we're looking at here is a theme or a
trend that you may have identified and you
want to actually play this theme in a
diversified way.
So not just using one stock long and one
stock short, you want to actually
represent this theme or trend by having
two stocks long and two stocks short.
And the theme we're looking at here is
discretionary versus essential retail
spend.
So we're looking at high-end retailers,
long and short low-end retailers.
And we're looking at how to hedge out
market risk in this trade.
So we're looking at long Macy's and Dill
odds and short target and family dollar.
So a couple of things here.
If we're looking at going long
discretionary versus essential retail
spend or long high-end retailers versus
short low-end retailers.
We're probably assuming here, well we are
assuming here, that our world view is
bullish.
So we're assuming that at this stage we've
gone through all the leading indicators
and they're pointing to GDP growth.
And we're expecting high GDP growth at
some point in the future.
And now we're looking at the retail sector
and deciding how we express that view
across the retail sector.
And if we're looking at long two stocks in
the retail sector and short two stocks in
the retail sector, essentially if we hedge
out market risk, we're also hedging out
sector risk.
So what we're looking at here is an
intra-sector spread trade.
So an intra-sector constituent spread
trade, the ones that we looked at earlier
in the presentation in previous videos.
So let's have a look at this trade and try
to work out how we hedge out the market
risk when we've got two stocks long and
two stocks short.
So let's assume in this portfolio we've
got a gross exposure of $100,000 and we
have a limit of $20,000 per theme.
So a self-imposed limit where we can't go
over $20,000 for one theme.
And what we've done here is we've assigned
beta values to the longs and the shorts.
These beta values are not the real beta
values.
These are fictional values that we've
assigned for illustrative purposes.
So if you wanted to get the real ones,
just go online, get the real ones or get
them in the spreadsheets from the
downloads areas in the videos.
So we're looking at four stocks here,
Macy's and Dillard's on the long side,
Target and Family Dollar on the short
side.
We've assigned to Macy's a beta of 1.01
and Dillard's 1.27.
Target 0.57 and Family Dollar 0.32.
And the first thing we're going to do is
work out how we apportion this money to
the long side of the portfolio and the
short side of the portfolio.
So what we do is we first work out the
gross beta, the total beta by adding up
all of these betas.
So we get to 3.17 and we also add up the
beta of the long side and we get 2.28 and
the beta of the short side and we get
0.89.
So intuitively, if we're going to
apportion this money, what we're seeing is
that the beta on the long side is a lot
higher than the beta on the short side.
Which kind of makes sense because if we're
looking at cyclicality on the long side or
more cyclical stocks on the long side than
on the short side,
you would expect higher betas on the long
side because the stocks, given that the
earnings are more sensitive to the
business cycle,
the stocks are probably going to move more
given a one unit move in the market than
the stocks on the short side.
So that's the first thing.
When we're going to apportion this money,
if we're going to apportion this money,
it's very obvious that the majority of
this money has to be apportioned on the
short side
and the minority of this money has to be
apportioned on the long side.
But how much on either side? Well, we can
work it out accurately.
So the next thing we do is we work out in
column F.
We work out the beta contributions or
weightings, percentage weightings of each
beta.
So Macy's, a beta of 1.01, divided by the
total beta of 3.17, gives 32%.
Dillard's 40%, target 18%, family dollar
10%.
We add up the beta or beta weightings for
the long side to get the beta weighting of
the long side to the total beta, which is
72%.
And we do the same on the short side.
We add up the weightings of the betas to
the total beta.
And we get the short side contribution of
beta to the total beta.
And this is 28%.
So we've got 72% beta contribution from
the long side, and we've got 28% beta
contribution from the short side.
Now, if we're apportioning this money, the
way we apportion it is actually the
inverse of these betas.
So we flip them, and we apportion our
money 28% on the long side and 72% on the
short side.
So that's the first thing we do.
We've worked out, out of this $20,000, how
much of it gets apportioned to the long
side and how much gets apportioned to the
short side.
Well, what gets apportioned to each side
is the inverse of the weightings of their
betas.
And that's pretty obvious, because if
we're going to hedge out market risk, then
clearly, because the short side moves a
lot less than the long side,
we have to apportion more of our money on
the short side than we do on the long
side.
Now, the next thing we have to do, we have
to work out, for example, so if we stay on
the long side for a second,
we have to work out, out of the 28% of the
$20,000 that we've apportioned on the long
side,
what percentage of that 28% is apportioned
to Macy's, and what percentage is
apportioned to Dillard's?
Well, let's use Macy's as an example, and
we'll show you how this is done.
So the first thing we do is we work out
the contribution of the Macy's beta to the
long beta of the trade.
So we divide 1.01 by 2.28, and we get 44%.
With Dillard's, we divide 1.27 by 2.28,
and we get 56%.
And then we work out, so let's have a look
at the formula bar here, H9 times G11.
We work out 44% of the 28%, which gives us
12.44%.
That's for Macy's.
And for Dillard's, we work out 55%, for
56% of the 28%.
And then, when we're apportioning our
money on the long side, we then have to
flip and do the inverse again
the percentage that we have to apportion
in Macy's and Dillard's.
So, in Macy's, we have to apportion 15.64%
of our money, and in Dillard's, we have to
apportion 12.44% of our money.
And this 15.64% and this 12.44% is the
total amount of the $20,000 that's
apportioned to the whole trade.
So, if we look at the short side, we'll
see that, if we go through the same
exercise, because Family Dollar has the
lowest beta,
when we repeat the same process on the
short side, Family Dollar, 46% of our
money has to be exposed to Family Dollar,
26% has to be exposed to Target.
And when we add up on the long side, the
percentages in the way that our money is
apportioned, we get the amount of money
that is apportioned to the long side.
And if we add up the percentages in the
way that our money is apportioned on the
short side, we get the percentage, 72%, we
get the percentage of our money that's
apportioned to the short side, making
100%.
So, we get the percentage of our money
that's apportioned to each position.
Then, we work out this in dollar terms.
So, we're working out, out of the 20,000,
so 15.64% of the 20,000, so just over
$3,000.
In Dillard's, $2,487.
Total dollars exposed on the long side,
$5,615.
On the short side, in Target, we're
apportioning $5,172.
And in Family Dollar, we're apportioning,
out of the $20,000, $9,213.
So, in total, $14,385.
So, that works out to be 72% and 28%.
We take the prices of each stock, and this
tells us how many shares that we have to
buy and sell.
And then, we're also working out here the
percentage size of these positions in our
portfolio.
So, this is just K9.
So, this is $3,128 divided by the
$100,000.
And we do this for each position, and the
long side, and the short side.
So, each position on the long side, and
the short side, and the total long side,
and the short side.
So, that's how you work out, from your
beta values, how you hedge out the market
risk in a theme that has two longs and two
shorts.
Now, you can get more complicated if you
want, where you have three longs and three
shorts, four longs and four shorts.
But, I wouldn't advise doing that to begin
with.
So, what you should probably be doing when
you start out is to try and make money
just doing spread trades, one stock long,
one stock short.
And then, when you're making money,
graduate to doing two stocks long and two
stocks short.
And if you can make money doing this, then
you can get more complicated later on.
You can get a little bit smarter and a bit
more cleverer once you're making money.
So, you can see this is a little bit
complicated.
You've got this spreadsheet in the
downloads area.
So, just download it and have a go at
reverse engineering the sheet yourself.
It's not that difficult to get used to.
So, these trades are quite typical trades
where if you have an idea, but you don't
want to have your exposure in just long
one stock and short one stock, you can
actually represent the same idea by
diversifying a little bit into two longs
and two shorts.
So, that concludes hedging out market risk
using beta across two longs and two
shorts.
Now, we're going to move on to the next
video and I'll see you in the next video.
Okay, welcome back.
So, that was an introduction to beta and
what we looked at there was beta across
two stocks and beta across a theme, as in
a theme that you've identified that you
believe that will happen as an overall
idea or trend within a certain industry.
And how you can represent that theme and
hedge out the market risk at the same time
is by having multiple longs and multiple
shorts representing the theme.
And you hedge out market risk in the
process.
And if you mechanically want to do that,
then just refer to that spreadsheet and go
through the steps.
With two single stocks, it's very
straightforward.
We just take the beta and the beta ratio
and this gives us our positioning and
sizes that we must put on on either side
of the trade.
Now, what we're going to do is do
something that you may not think occurs
immediately.
What we're going to do is have a look at
how we hedge out currency risk on a trade
across two geographies.
So, for example, if you take a position in
the United Kingdom and take a position in
the United States, you're actually going
to have an implied currency exposure.
And what we're going to look at is how we
hedge this exposure out.
Then we'll do a full summary of the risk
management parameters that we've looked at
for the portfolio.
But first, let's go over to the screen and
I'll show you how you effectively hedge
out currency risk.
OK, so welcome back to the computer
screen.
What we're going to have a look at here is
currency hedging.
And what you'll typically find when you do
cross country spread trades.
So a spread trade where you have a long
and a short in two different geographical
regions with two different currencies.
What you'll find is that when you do these
trades, you're going to end up with an
implied currency risk.
So what we're going to look at first is
just the idea of a currency as a spread
trade.
We're just going to pop back into the
watch list example, which you have in the
downloads area.
And we're just going to go into the
presentation and have a look at the one
particular slide which explains currency
risk.
So let's open up the watch list.
And this will be familiar to you where we
have all of our trade ideas on the example
watch list.
And if you scroll down, you'll see that we
have a section for Forex and we also have
a section for commodities, energy, metals
and food.
First things first, we just need to get
over this concept that a Forex trade is
actually just a spread trade by default.
So a currency trade is a spread trade by
default.
If you think about it, a currency trade is
a spread trade because you can't actually
buy a currency without selling another
currency first.
So when you're putting your currency
trades into your watch list, there is no
long and there is no short price.
There is just one entry price.
So if we have a look at EURUSD for
example, well, you can't buy dollars
without selling euros first in this
currency pair.
So the price is just the price.
And when you're putting and updating your
spreadsheet with your currency pairs, your
reference prices, when you're looking at
them, you put them on your watch list just
in the spread area here and
correspondingly in the spread column here.
And then when you're updating the currency
pair for the reference prices in the
current situation, you put them in the
current price here in the current spread.
So let's say, for example, EURUSD was on
the watch list seven weeks ago.
Well, seven weeks ago, it was around 128,
129.
And we put it again in here as the
reference price.
And then we have it here.
The current situation, which is EURUSD is
trading at 131.
So you just update it in that way.
There is no long and there is no short
entry.
That's just the price of buying dollars
and selling euros to do so.
So that's the first thing.
Now we're going to look at currency
hedging.
So what actually happens when you have a
long position in a stock or an asset in
one currency and a short position in a
stock or an asset in another currency.
So they're denominated in different
currencies.
Well, this comes into our portfolio
construction parameters area where you're
probably going to be setting this
parameter in your portfolio by making the
statement, well, if I do these trades, I
should just hedge out my currency risk to
begin with.
And it's fairly straightforward to
understand and very easy to do on pretty
much all brokerage platforms.
So instead of having a situation where you
go longer stock and shorter stock in the
same currency, we're now looking at doing
it in two different currencies.
And what that implies is that you have a
currency position.
So let's go through this example.
Let's say, for example, we wanted to buy
£20,000 of Standard Chartered, which is an
Asian bank with a listing in Asia, UK and
in the United States.
But we wanted to do this in pounds in
London.
So we're looking at buying £20,000 of
Standard Chartered and going short the
equivalent amount, £20,000 of Santander,
the Spanish bank.
So Standards is actually denominated in
sterling and Santander denominated in US
dollars if we're trading the New York
Stock Exchange listing.
Now, let's say the reference prices in the
market are £17.22 for Standards in London.
And for Santander in New York, the
reference price is $7.56.
And let's just assume that the sterling US
dollar cable rate is one and a half.
So £20,000 worth of Santander is
equivalent to $30,000.
Now, what happens is when we do a spread
trade, the stock that we purchase, we have
to pay for that purchase with the currency
that we're purchasing it in.
And when we short a stock, we actually
receive that currency.
Because when you're selling, you receive
the money for selling the stock.
So what you end up with is an implied
currency risk.
So in this example, if we buy Standard
Chartered, we pay pounds for the stock.
And if we short Santander, we receive the
US dollars.
Therefore, we end up receiving 30,000 US
dollars.
And we're short £20,000.
So what you have to do to hedge out the
currency risk here is you actually have to
do three trades.
You have to buy Standard Chartered.
You have to short Santander.
And then you have to buy £20,000 versus US
dollar to hedge out the currency risk.
So you do three trades in total.
And you do them all at the same time.
Now, why is this a risk?
Well, simply because if, for example, the
spread moves 10% in our favour,
but the currency moves 10% against us
during the lifetime that we have this
spread on,
then when we unwind the spread at the same
time,
so when we actually come to trade out of
the spread,
so selling Standard Chartered and buying
back Santander,
if the currency has moved against us,
that just means we won't actually make any
money.
So what you have to do is actually just
hedge out this currency risk right at the
beginning.
So if the spread does move in your favour,
the currency move doesn't cancel out the
move in the spread.
So that's pretty straightforward.
If you're doing this, just make sure that
you're aware of the currency risk
and make sure that if you don't want to
have that risk that you just hedge it out.
And you can do that very, very easily.
You just work out what your currency
exposure is.
So what you're paying for, what currency
you're paying in and what currency you're
receiving,
and then do the opposite trade and just
hedge it out and do all three of the
trades at once.
So you don't have the currency risk.
And then when you unwind, you just unwind
all three of the positions at the same
time.
So what are you going to see in your
brokerage account?
You're just going to see three positions.
You're going to see, in this example,
you're going to see long Standard
Chartered,
15,000 pounds worth.
You're going to see short Santander.
And you're going to see short $30,000
worth.
And then you're going to see a long
sterling US dollar position,
equivalent to 20,000 pounds or 30,000 US
dollars.
And that's basically it.
And then you just unwind that position, or
all three positions,
when you want to trade out of the spread.
So whether you're stopped out or you're
taking profits,
whenever you unwind, you just unwind all
three of them.
So very straightforward to understand.
Try to get your head around it.
It's just one of those construction
parameters that professional traders
understand
and make sure that they hedge out whenever
they can or if necessary.
So just understand it.
And when you get a little bit more
advanced,
as in when you begin spread trading,
you should probably just start by going
long and short stocks
that are denominated in the same currency.
But, you know, when you're making money
and you're getting a bit more advanced,
then this is something you'll probably
come across because you'll start wanting
to do spread trades
across geographies and across different
currencies.
And all you have to do is just understand
your currency risk, hedge it out,
and then when you unwind, you unwind all
positions at the same time.
Okay, so let's move on to the next video
and I'll see you on the other side.
Okay, so welcome back.
Now, in this video we've been through a
lot of risk management parameters that you
can deploy on your portfolio
to make sure, essentially, that you're not
being human.
You're doing the opposite of that and
you're making sure that the parameters are
in place and stop you from actually being
human.
So, these are very important because when
we go back to the trading psychology
module,
you'll know from that module that we have
to deploy these parameters to make sure
when we're in these situations that we do
the right thing.
And all professional hedge fund managers,
all professional traders who are running
long-short portfolios deploy these
parameters.
And they know that they have to to stop
themselves being human.
So, essentially, we're looking at pulling
from box A and pulling from box B at the
right times.
And the risk management parameters that we
looked at were gross exposure limits, net
exposure limits, single position limits.
We looked at hedging out certain risks as
well.
So, we looked at hedging out market risk
using beta across two positions, beta
across multiple positions.
And we also looked at hedging out currency
risk.
And we do this as professional traders
because we know that we shouldn't be
taking these risks unnecessarily.
And so, when actually we have to pull from
box B, we do so and we do it almost
robotically
and we know that if we protect our
downside in our portfolio, then as long as
that downside is protected, we live to
fight another day.
And on top of that, we can also have
winners which pay a lot more than the
downside that we've ensured or protected.
So, this enables you over the long term
when you have ideas through your idea
generation and trades through the
gatekeeping process that have been
deployed or ideas that have become trades
and they've now been put in the portfolio.
So, this ensures that your downside as a
trader is protected and this is why you
have to have risk management.
Now, you should absolutely go through this
video again and make sure you've got your
head around the basic risk management
principles.
We're going to go over to video number 24
now and Chris is going to show you a
pretty advanced technique for calculating
your own beta.
Let's go over to video number 24 and I'll
see you in video number 25.